You said of this
I don't know anything about that guy.
Francesca Francesca I don't know
anything about that guy. No, Francesca
can hear you. I don't know anything
about that guy. But I will speak Arabic
here. So maybe afterwards I can speak to
you, okay? Okay, my English is not bad,
but listen. Yeah, I know you. That's
what I'm saying, but we speak in Arabic
here. You just interrupted us. So let us
speak in Let us deal with our situation
first, then we come to you, okay? Okay.
All right. I thank you for Thank you.
Are you Muslim?
No. What do you believe? I believe I
believe in spirituality. Do you believe
in a creator? Yes. Okay, so that creator
Do you follow any particular religion or
you don't follow religion?
Well, yes, I do. Um
through Israel, Judah. Ah, so you
believe you follow the Old Testament,
the Bible. Okay. So if I ask you, how do
you know the Old Testament is from God?
Let me let me let me get this out of the
way first. No, no, no, no, no, no. Do
you want to hear No, no, this way you
Talking about God is is more important
than anything else. It's not so. Yes.
I appreciate you for exposing those who
are aiding the Zionists for killing
innocent Muslims. I appreciate that.
Thank you for that. However,
if you die, even if you support
Palestine, and you don't believe in the
true God, it will not benefit you. I
believe in the truth. That's what But
I'm asking you, how do you believe, cuz
you're following the Old Testament to
worship God?
How can you prove to me the Old
Testament is from God?
Can I prove it? Yeah, can you? No, I
can't. So this is different between us
and you. Cuz us Yes, of course. When you
look to the Quran, that's why the beauty
of Islam is Islam is not based upon
personal experience or just I had a
dream. No, Islam proves itself. So for
example, when you look to the Quran, the
Quran claimed to be from God firstly,
also challenged the people to bring
something like it in its eloquence, in
its presentation, prophecy, structure,
and even in its influence on people. Yet
no one is able to produce something like
the Quran. Bear in mind, the Prophet
Muhammad could not read and write.
He couldn't read and write. And he was
he was from the middle of nowhere. He
was in the middle of desert.
Like in the middle of desert. So a man
came with a book, challenged the people.
Also in the Quran, there's a prophecy
which shows the Quran from God.
Allah said in the Quran, "We have sent
the Quran to be memorized."
We have made for an easy to be
memorized. Now, it's impossible for
someone to live in the middle of nowhere
to make claims like this except if he
knows people everywhere of the future.
Now, if you go to Africa, Asia, Europe,
America, everywhere, the Muslims at the
age of 9 and 10, they don't even know
the Arabic language, yet they have
memorized it word for word and letter
for letter.
That's why as the Jewish people, as the
like the Christians,
they come together and they say, "You
know what? Let us get rid of scripture.
The only scripture will remain with us
is the Quran, cuz Allah promised that he
will preserve it. And we can put this
claim into a test." You understand? So
also, for example, there's a prophecy in
the Quran
Allah mentioned that that the people
would try to bring down the Quran to
bring down Islam. Yet Islam will
overpower everyone. And we know now the
fastest growing religion on the on the
face of the earth is Islam. Even though
Even though, pay attention to this,
yeah, which makes it more stronger and
powerful. Even though there is huge
barriers to stop Islam from spreading by
enemies of Islam. And also the enemies
of Islam, they have what? They have
stronger weapons. Who's Who's Who's in
control of the mainstream media?
Generally Generally speaking, the the
the the enemies of Islam. Yes. But he's
one of them. He's one of them. He's one
of them. But yet Islam is spreading. And
Allah mentioned that in the Quran.
Okay, but all I'm going to do I'm going
to give you a short message. Here's the
person you're supposed to be looking at
We promised that we're going to talk
about God more. Okay. We can't do both,
so I'm going to let you finish speaking
about God
and come back here. But I I I
What I say to you, look, when you go
home, raise your hands to the creator of
everything, the God of Abraham, the God
of Moses. He will guide you, too. Thank
you for everything. Thank you. All
right. All you need to know is contact
the UN,
Francesca Evanessia, and let her know
about Aldo Brandini. She's a Sicilian as
well. He's a Sicilian prince and he's
head of the British
you're talking about the about this,
yeah? I'm trying to stop the arms being
flooded
right. You're right. I I I was going to
mention I don't know what happened to
the Western world.
Take a picture.
Uh thank you.
Yeah, yeah. You bless you. But listen to
this. Listen to this, yeah? You know,
what happened in Palestine
is exposing the hypocrisy of the Western
world.
Absolutely. Who judge us crazy about
children's rights,
women's rights, while they see clearly
the Zionists killing the children and
women. When the war starts in Ukraine,
they were they were not accepting no
justification from Putin.
Even though Putin was saying Russia was
saying, "Ukraine started it. Ukraine
tried to do that." They said, "No
justification. You can't shoot the
women." But when Netanyahu, may Allah
curse him, Say amen. Amen.
curse Netanyahu. May Allah burn his son.
MAY ALLAH DESTROY HIM. This individual,
don't be scared. May Allah burn his
tongue and burn his limbs. This
individual, when he's trying to justify
killing children and women, the Western
world was accepting it.
Justification. To show you, if you're a
black or brown, there's no problem
killing children and women. But if
you're European, no big problem. See?
Alhamdulillah.
Of course. Of course. You see, I'm
talking deeper. That's why you want to
leave. You're talking like this,
brother, but I mean I talk deeper.
I go deep into the problem. I've gone to
the heart of the problem. First of all,
I don't know anything about that guy.
No, you told me this guy was just
holding a paper.
You understand? But I will look into it.
Thank you very much. Okay, so you don't
want to hear the whole the part of
why you can stop it if you contact
Francesca Evanessia.
All right, so you have to contact this.
She'd be the simplest person to contact
because he's a Sicilian, she's a
Sicilian. Okay. If you look on YouTube
for him
or Google, you won't find him. But it's
a kingdom called Brandini,
yes, in Sicily. Okay.
And he's the head of the British
establishment, not the king of England.
Okay.
Starmer's not in charge, neither.
They've just built an arms factory in
Newcastle owned by the Israeli state and
it's handed handed by
a peer from the Labour government. So
I'm showing you it's high treason.
So we have to contact the He'd be the
simplest person who would know.
what the people are watching going to
hear it. And what about what we say to
you? They're not going to stop.
Cuz what? Israel is the baby of America.
It's the loving baby of America. America
said clearly, "If there was no Israel,
we would create something just to
destabilize the
Arab countries."
Two countries have been created by the
Western world. One by France and one by
America, okay? So-called Israel and
Iran.
They're not Iran the country itself, but
the regime.
This Iranian regime is the best friends
of the Western world under the table.
It's known.
Okay, brother?
Uh it's all